it just seems like a really mean
nasty thing to do megan mccain hitting
back at sheri shepard for throwing shade
you know there's no need to be nasty
yeah it all started on watch what
happens live with andy cohen when sherry
revealed which co-hosts from the view
she's still friendly with i just
everybody not megan but everybody else
i'm so close to
so just days later when megan joined
andy on his serious xm radio show she
called out sherry for the unexpected
diss
i don't know sherry shepherd she was on
the show like 15 years before me when i
was in high school so i don't know why
anyone's under the impression that we're
close friends yeah like megan pointed
out the two never overlapped their time
on the talker i don't know why anyone
would be under the impression i'm close
friends with her like
i like obviously we are not and i'm not
up in my feelings about it i never think
about her at all it's unclear where the
bee first started but megan has a theory
about why it came up i think she's a new
show coming out she's looking for
publicity a really easy way to get
publicity is to try and fight with me
yeah sherry's new daytime show sherry
premiered on monday
now
your host sherry sheppard
and when et spoke with her ahead of the
show's kickoff she said she hopes the
show just makes you feel good sometimes
you just want to turn on the tv and feel
better than when you came so i want to
lift your spirits i have a need to do it
through laughter i want you to smile
that like this big gorgeous smile that
you have i want people to smile i want
people to feel seen i want women my age
to know that you still it's not too late
you can do anything that inspiring
message meg's not buying it it just
seems like a really mean
nasty thing to do in a very strange way
to start your new talk show that's
supposed to be like light and positive
for women to like trash someone and i
know what she's doing i mean we're all
smart she's like throwing shade and
making it a point to say like all the
alumni at the view get along and braid
each other's hair and go to sleepovers
except megan the ultimate mean girl bad
girl but this isn't the first time
shari's had some choice words about
megan she did it on your show
multiple times when i was on the view
and then obviously after and i don't
understand it which view guest was the
biggest disappointment once you met them
in person
oh i don't know i can't mccain wait
that was sheri earlier this year and
even back in 2018 the talk show host
gave her two cents on how megan could
improve as a panelist on the view she
just has to evolve she has to get used
to sitting there you are not the
republican voice i know and so it makes
you stress makes you tense and so i
think you know being able to just
lighten up a little i was super bummed
out when i saw her saying that she said
that i need to lighten up and with
sherry picking at old wounds again i
just everybody not megan but everybody
else
looks like the ladies won't be mending
fences anytime soon you know there's no
need to be nasty
[Music]